we need to take responsibility at the
community and local level rather than
simply solving every problem by spending
more and more federal dollars I not only
share it by enthusiastically endorsed it
it has to be all of us working together
not pointing fingers at each other but
working together thank you and I yield
back
thank you the gentlewoman from North
Carolina ms adams is recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you
secretary Carson for being here today
I'm over here let me we've had some
discussion today about the Choice
vouchers and many public housing
agencies have waiting lists and my
district in Charlotte North Carolina in
Mecklenburg we've got more than 30,000
people or on the wait list for Housing
Choice Voucher that includes women and
children and families people with
disabilities seniors young people and
the list goes on just if you can just
give me a yes of know that this cuz I'm
a couple other questions do you believe
that the federal government is
dedicating enough funding and resources
to ensure that individuals who are most
in need of housing can access an
affordable place to live what I'd love
to be able to give a lot more of course
okay thank you so given these severe
shortage of public housing and federal
rental assistance why did the budget
request for FY 20 2008 CDBG public
housing capital fund home and you only
asked for eight point seven billion less
than 2019 because we have to make tough
choices and a budget because we have a
twenty two billion dollar deficit debt
and we have children and grandchildren
and people who'll be coming after that
who will be responsible for that so real
compassion includes them as well
okay so is there when we talk about the
Housing Choice vouchers was any reason
that you didn't ask for more funding for
it for that for a reason what I love to
be
have enough for everybody to have what
they great okay let me let me ask this
question in terms of the vouchers we
have in 2016 we had one hundred twenty
six seven people hundred twenty seven
people in Charlotte that received the
voucher there 45 of those expired so
that means that individuals who were
searching for housing they were doing
that four hundred and twenty days
because I understand it's four months
and so they're gonna have to give them
back they've been turned away because
landlords and property managers don't
want to rent to folks with section 8
vouchers and so I think that there may
be some income source discrimination I
think that's unfair and that's simple
you know it's just plain and simple that
that's unfair so given this data do you
believe that we need a federal law
prohibiting discrimination I think we
certainly need to be looking at what are
the impediments for people to accept
those vouchers and that's exactly what
we're doing right now if we go through
that process and it's still a problem
maybe a federal law may be necessary
okay what about in terms of the folks
are having to give them back is there a
way to extend the time frame I mean for
months obviously it's not enough in some
cases there are hardship exemptions in
existence which can be utilized in those
situations okay since we have got a few
moments since you've rolled back the
affirmatively furthering fair housing
rule what specific actions is heard
currently taking to ensure its
guarantees are fulfilling their Fair
Housing obligations to tackle
segregation and housing discrimination
well when I took office there were 602
discriminatory actions we're down to
about a hundred now we've gone through
all of those and in addition to taking
care of the new ones that have come in
we'll get about
thousand a year so we have been
extremely active in pursuing those and
I've made it very clear to all the
organizations if anybody knows of
discriminatory activity that's going on
that we're not already addressing please
let us know okay have you have you
received any complaints at this point
like I said look at about 8,000 a year
and we deal with them as they come in do
you know about how many you've resolved
the resolution is about 80% thank you I
yield back the gentleman from Wisconsin
mr. Steele is recognized for five
minutes
Thank You chair water waters and thank
you secretary Carson for coming today I
want to talk to you about Opportunity
Zones in southeast Wisconsin with a
handful of opportunity zones in
particular on the cities of Janesville
Racine and Kenosha there's a lot of
opportunity in these opportunities owns
and people are quite excited about the
possibilities that they bring to bring
rejuvenation into these cities could you
comment on what you're working on at HUD
in supporting qualified Opportunity Fund
investments in housing yeah we we
actually have a lot of components that
are working on this for instance when it
comes to economic empowerment and
development the Commerce Department is
spearheading the activity when it comes
to entrepreneurship small business is
spearheading the activity when it comes
to education and Workforce Development
both the Labor Department and Education
Department when it comes to Safe
Communities and environmental concerns
the Department of Justice is
spearheading that and when it comes to
assessment of what's going on and
measurement the Council of Economic
Advisers is spearheading that so we have
a number of different spearheads
tackling the problems III appreciate
that and I would I would ask you if your
schedule permits some time to come to
southeast Wisconsin and explore
firsthand what opportunity these
opportunities zones present to some of
the communities on the area I have the
privilege I've been there before
Racine in particular at SC Johnson good
things going on there would love to have
you back I want to shift gears in my
limited time and talk about state and
local barriers to development and so
secretary Carson many of my colleagues
seem to believe that the the answer to
our housing is simply in the amount of
money we spend but I think we're coming
to a bipartisan consensus in its
emerging that we're recognizing also the
role of state and local barriers to
development in particular those that are
restricting access to housing on strict
land use laws in places in particular
like New York and San Francisco in Los
Angeles are making it hard to develop to
deliver affordable housing and this is
pricing low-income families out of their
neighborhoods it makes it hard for the
striving young people to move to a place
where jobs are actually plentiful can
you talk about the high regulatory cost
and how is making it harder for HUD in
local housing authorities to serve those
in need yeah well you know when you look
at zoning regulations for instance you
take a place like Los Angeles 70 to 80
percent of the land is zone for
single-family housing with a certain
amount of property and then you throw on
top of that all the regulatory barriers
including recently the need for some
solar input are you kidding me so this
just piles up and that's why you see
people who make 50 60 70 thousand
dollars a year living on the street and
tents this can be resolved but it needs
to be resolved with federal state and
low
authorities I understand that mayor
Garcetti has recently began to look at
allowing accessory dwelling units and
which will certainly help other
situation those are the kinds of things
though that we have to be looking at we
can as I said before we can solve this
problem if we don't make it political
let's just use what we have and solve it
I appreciate those comments it's an
incredibly important topic and we need
to continue to look at the local aspect
of these lands owning rules that are
driving up the cost of housing in very
particular communities in the United
States and I appreciate your time today
I yield back thank you thank you the
gentleman from New Jersey mr. Gant
heimer is recognized for five minutes
Thank You troubleman waters and Thank
You mr. secretary for being here today
one of the issues that I'm particularly
focused on is the tightening of the
credit box I know that you and my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle we
all agree that we need to expand access
to credit in a responsible manner so
that those who deserve to be in a home
can be we also know that HUD plays a
critical role in getting people in homes
secretary Carson in your opinion what's
the biggest factor that has caused the
credit box to shrink and what is HUD
doing to combat it fear
I think risk fear of risk and looking at
things that have happened historically
what are we doing about it we're trying
to expand the number of people who give
credit by alleviating some of their
anxiety I just mentioned to what we were
doing with the False Claims Act right so
that we can bring more people who can
provide credit into the market are you
seeing a shift I think it's starting to
shift absolutely it's it's gonna take a
while you know for people to to trust
what's going on but they will see over
the course of time that we're consistent
thank you and also I was hoping to ask
you about a specific extension of credit
and expanding started to talk about this
and
so one level down on the federal housing
authority loans right which you've
you've covered in your testimony
specifically you said that you've
noticed a greater number of borrowers
looking for FHA loans with higher debt
and lower credit scores and HUD is using
closer scrutiny before issuing these
mortgages to mitigate risk
how has cut HUD currently working to
strike a balance between promoting
access to credit via FHA loans and
managing risk well we're trying to look
at data and using that rather than just
using you know ideology when it comes to
issuing credit you know that really
comes back from my days in medicine
where evidence made a lot of difference
and that's the difference between the
fact that at the last turn of the
century before 2000 the average age of
death was in the 50s at 2000 it was
approaching the 80s the main difference
is that the medical profession began to
use evidence in their policy and it made
a huge difference in our longevity and
when you said closer scrutiny in your
testimony how do you is that using the
data how we're using the data
differently how how does that process
change if you don't mind me asking well
you look at things that you look at best
practices you look at things that have
worked in some areas and you say why is
that working you try to dissect that out
and then you see if you can make that
more broadly applicable great and I
thank you very much for your time today
thank you I yield back the gentleman
from Texas mr. Gordon is recognized for
five minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you
secretary Carson is there anything you
haven't talked about today you'd like to
discuss oh boy that opens up a big box
but I will tell you the thing that I am
most concerned about is the
affordability
saying you know we have more than 8
million families in the United States
who pay more than 50% of their income
for housing and you know we need to
really focus a lot of attention on that
get this problem solved
do you think spending more money will
solve that problem spending more money
is not the solution again getting to the
etiology of the price increases and what
can we do
that will enable us to build more
housing that more affordable housing
several of my colleagues have mentioned
you've been inaccessible have you met
with leadership of this committee and
with my colleagues across the aisle to
discuss their ideas I have tried the
chairwoman has not had time to meet with
me but I've met with several other
members and we've made some good
progress well I would encourage those
discussions to continue and I thank you
for your work and the hard work you've
done at your organization and for what's
to come thank you I yield back
thank you the gentlewoman from Virginia
miss Whitten is recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam chair and Thank You
secretary Carson for joining us here
today as you may be aware the house last
week passed the Equality Act which
includes a lot of broad protections for
the LGBTQ community but for our purposes
one of the things I'm most pleased about
is that there is the we are explicit
explicitly including the LGBTQ community
as a part of the Fair Housing Act
non-discrimination protections do you do
you agree with this inclusion well I'd
certainly agree with non-discrimination
and with being fair to every single
individual in our society so you're open
so you would approve of the inclusion of
LGBTQ community as a part of the Fair
Housing Act protections and illicitly
protecting them from describ
and housing if you want to include them
as one of the protected classes I think
that is something that Congress will be
responsible for very good and I guess
one of your responsibilities would have
to do with the rulemaking and the rules
for HUD and inclusion within HUD is that
correct and our responsibility is to
make sure everybody is treated fairly
and in March 2017 your agency remove
links to key resource documents
informing emergency shelters on best
practices for serving transgender people
facing homeless myth homelessness and
you withdrew a proposed policy that
would have required HUD funding funded
HUD funded emergency shelters to post
notice to residents to inform them of
their rights to be free of anti LGBTQ
discrimination under HUD regulations
right are we creating a situation where
there is more local jurisdictional
control but you removed that guidance
from the site and it has not been
replaced that's correct okay and last
month well you were testifying before
the House Appropriations Subcommittee
about HUDs withdrawal of these guidance
documents you said that they were not
needed and that the equal access rule
was in place that correct the rules from
2012 and 2016
ethically provide for so those rules are
still in place yes okay and you also
stated we have not made any attempt to
change them is that correct
we've not changed any of the rules and
that that was the case when you
testified in appropriations is that
still the case today
it's still the case okay and can you
assure this committee that you will not
make any that that HUD does not have any
current or future plans to eliminate the
equal access rule during the role in
rulemaking I'm not going to say what we
will do in the future about anything
are you currently anticipating doing
that I'm not currently anticipating
changing their rule what has your agency
done to ensure that the equal access
rule is implemented and that recipients
of HUD funding are aware of their risk
under the Equal Access rule we have left
the rules up from 2012 and 2016 and we
have made it very clear that we will
continue to enforce fairness for
everyone and when something is brought
to our attention that is not fair we
will deal with it so you're not being
proactive you're just going to be
reactive on this issue we are being very
proactive in terms of making sure that
discrimination is not occurring you just
testified that you took down the
guidance right the guidance was not
necessary the guidance was providing a
lot of regulatory input federal thumb on
everything as opposed to allowing local
jurisdictions to make their rules based
on the 2012 and 2016 so you don't think
it's appropriate for HUD to do that at
the national level not on that issue
okay so you have removed the guidance
you testify that you have no plans to to
eliminate the fair the equal access rule
but you're also not proactively
enforcing it you're waiting for
complaints to filter their way up to HUD
and then you'll deal with it is that
what you're saying you know one of the
things that I'm saying is if you want to
do something different about the
definition of gender and is a
congressional duty thank you I've no
further questions I'll yield back
the gentleman from Virginia mr. Rigell
Minh is recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman and ranking
member McHenry secretary Carson I
appreciate you taking the time to answer
all of our questions a day having xscape
poverty and lived in public housing you
certainly bring an important perspective
to many of the housing challenges we're
facing today and we are grateful to have
you here in your June 20 testimony
before the Financial Services Committee
you mentioned the issue of the FHA
having to deal with what you called very
archaic IT just last Thursday HUD
received a federal information
technology innovation award for
advancements in data analytics digital
transformation I'm a little bit familiar
with thank you could you expound on some
of the things HUD has been working on
over the last year to modernize old IT
systems and secondly in your opinion
what specific things still need to be
done in order to bring HUDs IT programs
up to date well you know still a lot of
our platforms are 40 years old so
technology's been left behind but what
we have done is been able to create a
dashboard that gives us real-time
information about where our grant money
is and how it's being spent and this
allows us to provide more flexibility to
the various jurisdictions so that's
something that I'm very excited about in
FHA
you know thanks to Congress we've been
able to at least start updating you know
our information technology platforms
it's it's going to take you know quite a
bit more and but but we're getting there
and that's the important thing because
you know we don't want to fall behind
all the other servicers and that puts a
lot of taxpayer money at risk but it
also makes us inefficient and that's
something that we want to change as
quickly as possible thank you because I
think 40 years ago I was playing pong so
I'm glad there you see there's some
advancements going on here
so thank you for that and another topic
I would like to address are Opportunity
Zones and and the reason there is
because I have the big
district in Virginia it's actually
bigger than six states it's bigger than
New Jersey and we have the most even
though we have one of the eleven
districts I think we have 18 percent of
the opportunity zones throughout the
entire state they were created under the
tax codes and Jobs Act of 2017 to
stimulate economic growth and job
creation could you discuss some of the
things HUD is doing to incentivize as
far as incentivizing economic growth and
low income communities to opportunity
zones and do you see the criteria for
designating opportunity zones changing
or expanding in the future yeah you know
we're providing preference points for
people who are willing to go into
opportunity zones and you know you can
buy something there you can build
something there you can invest in
something there there are a number of
mechanisms that you can utilize we're
also providing expertise people who can
help people create programs that will
attract other resources into the area
and ways to partner with entities that
already exist within the opportunity's
own and and as everybody knows or we
have a very supportive opportunity zones
especially with with the fifth District
of Virginia having so many and we don't
have a lot of time but I think I have
one more question here and I thank you
again very much for answering these
questions over the last several years
we've seen a dramatic increase in
natural disasters in my district
particularly we've been affected by
multiple hurricanes and flooding in your
opinion how would you rate HUDs response
to the most recent disasters well we've
had an unprecedented number of disasters
since I became the HUD secretary I hope
I haven't caused them but the fact of
the matter is I think the response has
been good I'm never satisfied with it
that's why I'm always asking is there
something else we can be doing to get
these funds out faster but do recognize
that
HUD is the long-term entity when it
comes to a disaster
SBA FEMA Army Corps Engineers those are
the short-term responders having said
that I still want to speed the process
up so the whole concept of codification
and in certain arenas is a good concept
taking out unnecessary steps a very good
concept and I would I would personally
like to get it down to you have a
disaster six months you've got
everything you need
Thank You secretary Carson very much and
I yield my time the gentlewoman from
California miss Porter is recognized for
five minutes
good afternoon mr. Carson are you in
favor or opposed to adjusting the
interest curtailment penalty schedule
for FHA loans that are in default I
don't know that I can say broadly I
think you asking you to state
specifically I think you got to look at
specific cases in some cases I might be
in favor of in some cases I might not
okay do you know what the interest rate
curtailment schedule is at FHA and how
it's different from the GSEs well we we
tend to try to maintain a lower interest
rate
FHA sir I'm asking you about debenture
interest curtailment penalties explain
so so FHA uses different servicing and
conveyance procedures than the GSEs do
and the result of this is that the cost
of servicing mortgage servicing at FHA
for a non-performing mortgage is three
times the cost of doing the equivalent
servicing at the GSEs for a
non-performing loan that triple wing of
cost
in servicing which then has the effect
of reducing the credit availability to
the American people because when you
drive up servicing costs then servicers
overlay with cost overlays and it makes
the loans more expensive for the very
homeowners that FHA is designed to serve
so my question I'm trying to drive at
here is why is FHA to use a term that I
think we can both understand lousy at
servicing mortgages okay I have not had
any discussions about that particular
issue but I will okay as you look it up
I'd also like you to get back to me if
you don't mind to explain the disparity
in REO rates do you know what an REO is
and Oreo
are not an Oreo an REO real estate
what's the O stand for the organization
owned real estate owned that's what
happens when a property goes to
foreclosure we call it an REO and FHA
loans have much higher REO s that is
they go to foreclosure rather than to
loss mitigation or to non foreclosure
alternatives like short sales than
comparable loans at the GSEs so I'd like
to know why we're having more
foreclosures that end in people losing
their homes with stains to their credit
and disruption to their communities and
their neighborhoods at FHA than we are
at the GSEs I would be extremely happy
if you'd like to have you work with the
people who do that well mr. Carson
though respectfully that was my day job
before I came to Congress so now it's my
job to ask you working with the people
at HUD on this problem so what I would
like you to do is to take this back to
FHA and to ask the folks at FHA because
since 2007 I have been writing about the
problems in FHA servicing I am a huge
fan of FHA I'm a believer in their
mission and I am A champion for them are
you of course I believe in the mission
of FHA are you a champion for the
institution the organization very much
so okay so let
make sure you understand when a loan
that the most common outcome for an FHA
loan that goes into default is REO
there's a conveyance process are you
familiar with this I know about all
right so let me ask you about conveyance
what actions is HUD taking to change the
conveyance process at FHA to address the
loss recovery differential between FHA
loans and GSE loans well again you're
getting way down in the weeds here and
there's real American people out of
their houses so they are literally in
the weeds when they are foreclosed on
understood and I'm very happy to put you
in contact with the people who deal with
that if I got down the weeds on every
issue wouldn't get very far okay
appreciate it but this has been a
problem for years the Urban Institute
issued a major report on this and I will
be happy to send you a copy I appreciate
you bringing to my attention I want to
make sure you let me ask you this given
these problems the outcome is that FHA
is the leading cause of blight at homes
in the United States what can you do
about that
do you understand the relationship
between the blight and the servicing
problems I understand that blight is a
huge problem and then it comes through
your agencies in action on servicing I'm
not sure that I'm willing to accept that
FHA is the cause of all the blight that
we have I hope you feel differently
after you read the report thank you
gentleman from Illinois mr. Garcia is
now recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chair and secretary
Carson thank you for being here with us
today in engaging us in conversations
about HUD I want to begin with a
proposal pending before this committee
are known as the safe housing and
Families Act
it recognizes and seeks to take action
in the aftermath of
13 deaths that have occurred in
federally subsidized housing since 2003
including as recently as February when
Anthony and Gwendolyn Fleming died of
carbon monoxide poisoning at Hickory
Hollow Cooperative a HUD subsidized
causal housing complex in Wayne Michigan
near to your childhood home the
Fleming's death where the third and
fourth deaths to occurred this year
since April as you know HUD has been
developing a rule to put an end to this
to these preventable deaths by requiring
co2 detectors in public housing but it
could be many months before that rule is
finalized as the process goes on Friday
a story ran an NBC News website in which
HUD a HUD spokesperson is quoted as
saying quote Congress can fix this by
passing legislation requiring carbon
monoxide detectors for those living in
HUD housing units where detectors
detectors are needed Sir Terry Carson
that legislation is before this
committee today this is that public
hearing the safe housing for families
Act would codify the rule so that you
are developing into law and would
provide 10 million dollars in funding
over ten years to carry out the
objective of stopping avoidable that's
like the ones I mentioned this is double
the amount of that you that HUD
announced yesterday would be made
available secretary Carson would you
support the safe housing for families
Act as I've mentioned to you in the past
I am a hundred percent for getting this
carbon monoxide issue settled I
appreciate your help in helping getting
that done and as quickly as we can get
it done it's going to get done
great thank you secretary I accept your
endorsement
Toomes changing gears and returning back
to our topic we were discussing
previously the mixed-status rule like to
share with you a story about Joe
spell she was raised in Chicago and has
always struggled to have clean green
safe and affordable housing she's